wissen Sie was Anthroposophie ist
ich wette sie kommen öfter mit ihr in
Berührung als Sie denken ohne es zu
merken
[Musik]
Sie haben doch bestimmt schon mal im
Supermarkt Demeter Produkte gesehen oder
gekauft oder was von Waldorfschulen
gehört beides ist doch gefühlt irgendwie
gut nachhaltige Biolandwirtschaft und
freies kreatives lernen
genau auf diesem Wissensstand war ich
bis vor einem Jahr auch ich hatte
ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung was andere
Philosophie ist welches denken dahinter
steckt dann habe ich immer wieder gehört
dass Anthroposophen eine treibende Kraft
der querdenkerbewegung sein
das fand ich spannend und wenn der Sache
in den letzten Monaten mal nachgegangen
ich wollte wissen was hat es mit der
Anthroposophie eigentlich genau auf sich
was will sie wie ticken ihre Anhänger
die andere persönliche Bewegung ist groß
also Menschen die irgendwie Beziehung zu
anderen Sophie haben betrifft eine
Million zwei Millionen Menschen ja die
andere Philosophie ist ja die größte
esoterische Strömung in Europa und wirkt
super weit und tief in die Gesellschaft
mit rein
die andere Sophie
Wissenschaftsfeindlichkeit im Gegenteil
was halten sie von anthroposophischer
Medizin Blitz gefährlich was ich
rausgefunden habe hat mich überrascht
und ja auch erschreckt Anthroposophie
ist viel tiefer in unserer Gesellschaft
verankert als wir denken es gibt
Stiftungen die mit Milliarden dafür
sorgen dass sie sich ausbreitet vor
allem in der Medizin ganz ähnlich wie
bei der Homöopathie und in
Anthroposophie steckt viel Esoterik sehr
viel mehr als die meisten von uns wissen
und jetzt ist die entscheidende Frage
wie gefährlich kann das sein
[Musik]
was ist Anthroposophie eigentlich ich
gehe auf Spurensuche
hier liegt das Zentrum der
Anthroposophie in diesem spektakulären
Bau in Dornach in der Schweiz das
Goetheanum
er baut hat es Rudolf Steiner ein
Philosoph und selbst einander Hellseher
er hat die Anthroposophie vor gut 100
Jahren begründet
was ist Anthroposophie
das heißt der Weisheit vom Menschen
Anthroposophie Weisheit von Menschen
das ist Wolfgang Held seit 20 Jahren
arbeitet er hier am Goetheanum
bei Führungen will er Menschen wie mir
die anthroposophische denke näher
bringen zwar andere
Welt mit dem Gespräch im Innern zu
verbinden es geht nicht nur um
spirituelle Erhöhung und innerliche
Erweiterung der Seele es geht darum in
der Welt was zu verändern andere sophie
hat als einzige Reformbewegung im 20
Jahrhundert den Praxistest bestanden mit
Banken mit Kliniken mit Landwirtschaft
mit Schulen
schauen wir doch mal in unseren Alltag
wo ist überall Anthroposophie zu finden
Demeter anthroposophisch welleder
anthroposophisch Marken wie Wala dr
hauschka die natursäfte von Völkel die
GLS Bank alle anthroposophisch es gibt
mehr als 250 Waldorfschulen in
Deutschland das gibt anthroposophische
Ärzte mehr als 1.600 es gibt sogar neuen
anthroposophische Kliniken dazu Big
Player die stark anthroposophisch
geprägt sind wie zum Beispiel DM die
Drogeriekette oder Alnatura Marktführer
mit Milliarden umsetzen
[Musik]
mir war das ehrlich gesagt überhaupt
nicht klar wie tief die Anthroposophie
in unserer Gesellschaft in unseren
Alltag verankert ist
[Musik]
wie viele anthroposophinnen und
Anthroposophen ist genau in Deutschland
gibt es schwer zu sagen es gibt dafür
keine belastbaren Zahlen was man aber
sagen kann die Anthroposophie ist in der
Mitte der Gesellschaft angekommen gerade
hier in Baden-Württemberg und mit ihr
eine esoterische auf übersinnlichen
Kräften beruhende Weltanschauung die oft
im krassen Gegensatz zur Wissenschaft
steht
[Musik]
nehmen wir doch mal Demeter mehr als
1.700 DM Betriebe gibt es in Deutschland
ein Drittel davon in Baden-Württemberg
wieder reiherhof von Christoph
senffendörfer hallo guten Morgen
danke für die Einladung
Demeter Inbegriff des Guten Vorreiter
einer ökologischen Landwirtschaft lange
bevor biotrend war von den Verbrauchern
wurde Demeter vor kurzem zur
nachhaltigsten Marke Deutschlands
gewählt
1,15 Milliarden Euro Umsatz wurde 2021
mit Demeter Produkten erwirtschaftet das
sind fast 400 Millionen Euro mehr als
noch 2019
[Musik]
was aber die wenigsten wissen in diesem
so beliebten demeter-produkten stecken
kosmische Kräfte die der Hellseher
Rudolf Steiner vor 100 Jahren entdeckt
haben will
[Musik]
so werden zum Beispiel Quarz oder
Kuhmist in Kuhhörner gefüllt und ein
halbes Jahr in die Erde vergraben und da
ich zitiere von der Demeter Homepage
kosmische Kräfte zu sammeln dann werden
diese Kuhhörner ausgegraben und der
Inhalt als quasi kosmischer Dünger stark
verdünnt auf die Felder verteilt
[Musik]
offiziell spricht man dabei von
biodynamischen Präparaten sie sollen das
Wachstum der Pflanzen positiv
beeinflussen
wenn ich jetzt pflanzen mit Kunstdünger
ernähre dann werden die Pflanzen die
Blätter schwer und haben weniger
Kontakt zum Sonnenlicht während wenn wir
wenn sie biodynamisch angebaut werden
dann dann dann dann machen die richtig
so eine Geste wo die Blätter sich so in
die Sonne stellen und die Sonnenlicht
die Sonnenlicht viel stärker aufnehmen
und umwandeln können
[Musik]
nur einen naturwissenschaftlichen
Nachweis dafür gibt es nicht
Christoph simpendörfer sagt die
Wissenschaft könne eben nicht alles
erfassen die Wirklichkeit sei mehr und
die Erfahrung die eigene Beobachtung
gebe den Demeter Landwirten recht
erklären Sie mir mal was es mit diesem
kohhörnern genau auf sich hat nur damit
ich es verstehe die sollen ja kosmische
Antennen sein wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe
ja wenn wir die Kühe im Stall beobachten
und beobachten wie sie verdauen da kann
man zum Beispiel beobachten dass die
Hörner der Kuh also wenn ich Hörner
wegnehme dass ich der Schädelform
verändert man kann beobachten wie der
Mist von Kühen sich verändert wenn sie
enthornt werden und so erklären wir uns
warum Rudolf Steiner angeregt hat man
möge doch einnehmen und da den Mist rein
tun und das dem winterkräften Aussetzen
und das entsprechend anwenden das ist
für uns wie ein natürliches Heilmittel
das wird dem Boden beigeben und dadurch
die Kraft im Boden stärken
Homöopathie für den Boden dann oder
so kann man das bezeichnen ja müssen das
eigentlich alle demeterhöfe so machen
mit den Präparaten mit dem Kuhhorn genau
das ist das ist Bestandteil unserer
Richtlinien das ist halt so ein bisschen
ein Kernstück also verpflichtend das ist
verpflichtender können Sie verstehen
dass wenn jemand das von außen hört dass
er Kuhhörner vergraben werden mit
Präparaten die dann irgendwelche
kosmischen Energien aufnehmen sollen und
dann wird das verdünnt und dann auf die
Felder gebracht und das bringt was dass
da Leute von außen sagen sorry das ist
hokuspokus
das kann ich natürlich nachvollziehen
meine Erfahrung bei meinen vielen
betriebsrundgängen und Führungen die ich
mache wo ich den Menschen versucht
nahezubringen dass die Welt eben aus
Meer als aus stofflichen Wirkungen
besteht
stoße ich eigentlich immer wieder auf
Fehlverständnis
[Musik]
ich habe mich im Gespräch mit Christoph
senfendorfer an das Spiel ich sehe was
was du nicht siehst erinnert gefühlt
andere Personen geben vor was zu sehen
was andere nicht sehen und was die
Wissenschaft nicht erfassen kann lange
hat man das abgetan hat gedacht ist ja
nicht schlimm wenn jemand an kosmische
Kräfte glaubt und Kuhhörner vergräbt
schadet ja nicht spätestens hat der
Pandemie aber stellt sich die Frage ob
es nicht doch schadet ob diese
anthroposophische Einstellung die
Wissenschaft ist begrenzt die
Wissenschaft ist nicht alles eben
Zweifel an der Wissenschaft sät und
genau das kann man immer wieder
beobachten ein Beispiel Waldorfschule
mehr als 250 davon gibt es in
Deutschland der pädagogische Arm der
Anthroposophie Waldorfschulen waren
schon immer Hochburgen der impfskepsis
schon vor Corona gab es an
Waldorfschulen auffallend viele
masernausbrüche und während Corona
auffallend viele maskenbefreiungsarteste
an manchen Waldorfschulen hat mehr als
10% der Schülerinnen und Schüler solche
Atteste Zufall
[Musik]
das ist die Waldorfschule in Itzehoe
350 Schülerinnen und Schüler werden hier
unterrichtet
ich treffe Jürgen beckmarhagen damals im
Februar 2022 noch Geschäftsführer hier
er ist kein Anthroposoph aber glühender
Fan der Waldorfpädagogik
[Musik]
beckmar Hagen wurden als Geschäftsführer
immer wieder
maskenbefreiungsarteste von den gleichen
Ärzten oft im gleichen Wortlaut
vorgelegt
es gibt zwei Ärzte hier bei uns im Kreis
ich werde jetzt hier den nicht den Namen
nennen die einfach dafür bekannt sind
dass eben im Grunde genommen eine
testzuschreiben so wie es benötigt wird
ja und entsprechend müssen wir dann auch
diese Attest so anerkennen ja heißt das
dass wenn es Ärzte gibt die
gefälligkeitsartteste ausstellen dass
Sie als Geschäftsführer da im Grunde
total machtlos sind gar nicht machen
kann sie können die atte auch nicht
irgendjemanden vorlegen irgendeiner
Behörde vorlegen oder wem auch immer um
die prüfen zu lassen
rein rechtlich darf ich es nicht
beckenhagen dies die Ärztekammer
Schleswig-Holstein auf die Praktiken der
beiden Ärzte hin
die Ärztekammer hat dann aber sag jetzt
einfach mal dummerweise das schreiben
was ich an die Ärztekammer gerichtet
hatte eine der beiden Ärzte
weitergeleitet und der Arzt hatte nichts
Wichtigeres zu tun als dieses Schreiben
zusammen mit irgendwelchen Aussagen von
Rudolf Steiner und ein Bild von Rudolf
Steiner ins Internet zu stellen und
gleichzeitig vor der Waldorfschule
Itzehoe zu warnen
Ärzte für den Frieden Impfstoff soll
Seele der Menschheit entfernen Rudolf
Steiner schrieb vor über 100 Jahren in
Zukunft werden wir die Seele mit Medizin
beseitigen Waldorfschule
Itzehoe danke dafür das mag ein letzter
Bahnhof für viele Eltern sein die noch
darauf vertrauen hier würde nach den
Grundsätzen Rudolf Steiners gewirkt das
haben dann auch gleichzeitig wiederum
andere Telegramm Kanäle aufgegriffen die
vielleicht noch ein bisschen extremer
sind
das hatte dazu geführt dass mich dann
die Beratungsstelle gegen
Rechtsextremismus vor Angriffen von
rechts gewarnt hatten also das war dann
so eine Art Kampagne gegen sie ja klar
inzwischen ist Jürgen beckmarhagen wie
geplant in den Ruhestand gegangen
aber um das noch mal zusammenzufassen
ein Geschäftsführer einer Waldorfschule
der sich gegen zweifelhafte
maskenbefreiungsarteste zur Wehr setzen
will sieht sich massiven Anfeindungen
ausgesetzt im Namen Rudolf Steiners im
Namen der Anthroposophie
[Musik]
in der Pandemie geht ein Riss durch die
anthroposophische Bewegung Teile
radikalisieren sich
[Musik]
sympathisieren offen mit der
querdenkerszene ja die Badische Zeitung
nannte den Oberarzt von der
anthroposophischen Klinik in Arlesheim
mal der Arzt dem die corona-leugner
vertrauen
und offenbaren einen extrem esoterisches
Weltbild es gibt die Haltung des Globuli
aus dem Weltall aus meteorstaub vor
Corona schützen
kaum einer verfolgt das alles so
akribisch wie Oliver Rautenberg er führt
seit Jahren einen kritischen
anthroposophie-block
vergangenes Jahr wurde er dafür für den
Grimma Online-Preis nominiert die Frage
ist diese extrem esoterischen Stimmen
kommen die
vom Rand der Bewegung oder kommen die
aus der Mitte der Bewegung ich würde
eher sagen sie kommt vom Kopf der
Bewegung wenn wir schauen woher diese
querdenkerischen Positionen kommen die
impfgegnerischen die
maßnahmengegnerischen die
staatskritischen dann ist es eben aus
den zentralen der Anthroposophie ist und
es sind auch die quasi Führungsfiguren
der Anthroposophie die solche Dinge dann
äußern wer ist das z.B hier haben wir
ein Beispiel der Markus Sommer spricht
davon dass die kosmologischen Aspekte
schon bei der Spanischen Grippe und
dieselben gewesen wären wir heute bei
der corona-pandemie Jupiter und Saturn
stören den Kopf Brust drücken muss das
heißt ungünstigen Planetenstellung
führen quasi direkt zu der Entstehung
von Pandemien also quasi eine
astrologische Deutung der Pandemie oder
da gab es die Michaela Glöckler über 30
Jahre lang Leiterin der medizinischen
Sektion angekommen die nicht nur der
Überzeugung war wir müssen den Virus
oder das Virus als unseren Freund sehen
sondern sich auch für eine Durchseuchung
ausspricht und immer noch behauptet
Corona sei zum Beispiel die Rache für
das Tierleid ja wir haben den Tieren
schreckliches angetan die Tiere werden
gequält sie schreien die
Geräusche unserer Massentierhaltung ja
das geht auch alles in die Luft und das
Atmen wir auch alles ein das heißt das
was wir den Tierwesen angetan haben
Recht sich jetzt quasi dadurch dass wir
die die gequälte Luft aufnehmen in uns
und dadurch eine Lungenkrankheit
bekommen es wird ja jetzt durch das
pandemiemanagement die total Überwachung
geprobt das ist ein Zitat von Michael
das hört sich ja schon sehr nach
querdenkersprech an oder absolut und
welchen Einfluss hat so eine Michaela
Glückler zehntelang das Aushänge Schild
und die weltweit bekannteste und
renommierteste philosophische
Medizinerin Autorin Forscherin und hat
halt die anthroposophische Medizin stark
geprägt
wenn man sich in die Schriften von
Michaela Glöckler genauer einließt kommt
man dem esoterischen Kern der
Anthroposophie auf die Spur
in der anthroposophischen Lehre spielen
nämlich Wiedergeburt und Karma eine
entscheidende Rolle wir Menschen werden
wiedergeboren und wir tragen in unserem
heutigen Leben quasi ein Schicksal mit
aus unseren früheren Leben und das
bedeutet zum Beispiel wenn man krank
wird dann kann das damit zu tun haben
dass man sich in einem früheren Leben
nicht richtig verhalten hat und dass das
jetzt ausgeglichen werden muss durch die
Krankheit Beispiel wenn man in einem
früheren Leben kein Interesse an den
Sternen hatte dann kann das jetzt zu
Bindegewebsschwäche führen wenn man kann
Interesse an Musik hatte zu
Lungenkrankheiten das ist kein Scherz
kann man alles nachlesen bei Michaela
Glöckler der Grandt dann der
anthroposophischen Medizin
das ist natürlich krass denn das würde
ja bedeuten dass wir eine
Mitverantwortung tragen für Krankheiten
die wir heute haben weil wir uns in
einem früheren Leben so oder so
verhalten haben
das anthroposophische
Gemeinschaftskrankenhaus Havelhöhe in
Berlin ich bin hier mit Harald Matthes
verabredet er hat die Klinik 1995
mitbegründet und leitet sie bis heute
neben moderner Notfallmedizin werden
hier auch die zusätzlichen
Behandlungsmöglichkeiten der
anthroposophischen Medizin Angeboten der
Mensch soll hier mit seinen
Selbstheilungskräften im Mittelpunkt
stehen eine besondere Zuwendung erfahren
zum Beispiel durch Musiktherapie
guten Tag Frau ich bin wieder da und ich
würde für sie was wieder spielen
[Musik]
aber spielen hier auch Karma und
wiedergeburts eine Rolle glauben Sie
eigentlich an Wiedergeburt
wie ist es für mich verständlich dass
der eine Mensch
wie Mozart auf die Erde kommt und setzt
sich ans Klavier und legt los und macht
mit vier Jahren die ersten Konzerte ist
das genetisch hat er das alles äh
gelernt oder hat das etwas mit seinem
Geist zu tun der Fähigkeiten mitbringt
und jetzt genau woher und jetzt können
wir natürlich davon ausgehen dass all
das was ich mir erworben habe als
Fähigkeit ist dann mit dem Tod weg oder
aber ich erlaube mir den Gedanken dass
der Geist auch unabhängig von der
Materie bestehen kann
also der Geist kann nach Harald Matthes
wiedergeboren werden und bringt
Fähigkeiten mit aber bringt er auch und
das ist ja medizinisch ganz wichtig
Krankheiten mit
glauben Sie daran dass Krankheiten in
unserem hiesigen Leben was zu tun haben
könnten mit Verfehlungen in einem
anderen Leben das kann ich nicht sagen
weil ich kann nur sagen dass viele
Krankheiten 80 Prozent unserer
Krankheiten haben was mit unserem
Lebensumständen zu tun also alle
chronischen Erkrankungen in der
westlichen Welt ja klar wir haben aber
auch einige Krankheiten wo wir überhaupt
nicht verstehen woher die kommen
und Sie glauben dass das mit
Verfehlungen aus früheren Leben ich
glaube das nicht sondern ich habe nur
die Frage das was die Menschen zu
Menschen ausmacht ist ja dass er es
eigentlich schaffen sollte sein
seelisches und sein lebendig leibliches
sozusagen zu einer Einheit zu einer
Identität zu bringen so dass er eine
starke Persönlichkeit ist und wenn ihm
das weniger gelingt dann hat ihr
vielleicht seelische Verfehlungen
dass wir unseren Krankheiten zum Teil
selbst schuld sind
naja ich glaube auch dass zum Beispiel
eine Leberzirrhose eine Folge der
Verhaltensweise von Alkoholkonsum ist
ich glaube auch die riesigen leben das
ist ja ein riesen Unterschied nee
sondern es ist doch jetzt genau der
Punkt woher kommen denn bestimmte
seelische verhaltensdevation und jetzt
ist doch nur die Frage kann es nicht
sein dass bestimmte Dinge
wo man manchmal merkt ich weiß nicht
woher die kommen jedenfalls ich verstehe
sie nicht aus diesem Leben dann kann ich
als eine der Thesen offen lassen ob das
etwas mit meiner Geschichte als seelisch
geistiges Wesen zu tun hat was ich jetzt
noch nicht verstehe
Harald Matthes der ärztliche Leiter und
Geschäftsführer eines Krankenhauses will
also nicht ausschließen dass
Verfehlungen aus einem früheren Leben
Einfluss auf Krankheiten heute haben
können
es gibt so eine Art doppelsprech nach
außen hin wirkt die Anthroposophie damit
die Medizin menschlicher zu machen
und ja es gibt hier eine besondere Form
der Zuwendung
aber unter der Oberfläche ist eine
esoterische Ideologie am Berg geht es
plötzlich um Karma und Reinkarnation was
nur die wenigsten wissen
und es werden hier auch ganz
selbstverständlich anthroposophische
Arzneimittel verabreicht bei denen
höhere kosmische Kräfte ihre Heilwirkung
entfalten sollen die rudolf-steiner vor
100 Jahren entdeckt haben will
[Musik]
Meteoreisen zum Beispiel
was ist das eigentlich genau
also
Meteoreisen ist
Eisen was über ein Meteoriten also aus
dem Weltall entsprechend auf die Erde
gekommen ist und was wir eben eingesetzt
haben in der Kurve Infektion und im
Sinne der anthroposophischen Medizin
versuchen wir mit diesen
anthroposophischen Medikamenten
Regulativ in das Verhältnis der
verschiedenen
sein Schichten des Menschen zwischen dem
was sein physische lebendiger Körper ist
und zwischen dem was das seelisch
geistige ist in der Interaktion zu
beeinflusst gibt es für das Meteoreisen
ein wissenschaftlichen Beleg für das
Meteoreisen für das ferrum als alleinige
Therapie nicht sondern das was wir haben
ist eine Studie aus der Kinderheilkunde
wo es gezeigt hat dass es effektiv ist
aber es war kombiniert mit anderen
Medikamenten die noch gleichzeitig
gegeben wurde
[Musik]
da ist es wieder dieses ich sehe was was
du nicht siehst Gefühl aber was anderes
ist noch entscheidend und zwar die Frage
nach dem Geld die Anthroposophie wäre
nie so einflussreich geworden wenn sie
nicht sehr reiche Förderer hätte
Förderer aus der Mitte der bürgerlichen
Gesellschaft
Menschen die ihn Peter schnell er hat
vor mehr als fünf Jahrzehnten die
Software AG gegründet einen der größten
IT-Konzerne Europas mit Hauptsitz in
Darmstadt Umsatz knapp eine Milliarde
Euro den Großteil seiner
Unternehmensanteil hat Peter schnell in
die Software AG Stiftung überführt sie
ist mit dem Stiftungsvermögen von knapp
1,4 Milliarden Euro eine der größten
privaten Stiftungen in Deutschland und
eines der zentralen Ziele der Software
AG Stiftung ist die Förderung der
anthroposophischen Medizin dafür haben
anthroposophische Mediziner zusammen mit
der Software Stiftung ein Masterplan
entworfen kann man hier nachlesen in den
Tätigkeitsberichten der medizinischen
Sektion am GTA der Masterplan zur
sogenannten Akademisierung der
anthroposophischen Medizin ist gut
angelaufen in all dieser Hinsicht
gebührt Dank den großzügigen Sponsoren
allen voran der Software AG Stiftung
dieser Masterplan ist die
anthroposophische Medizin salonfähig zu
machen also auf Augenhöhe zu bringen mit
der klassischen Medizin und wie will man
das hinkriegen man wollte in die
deutschen Unis rein man wollte das
Anthroposophen Professoren werden
deshalb hat die Software AG Stiftung
seit 2008 die Habilitation von
anthroposophischen Medizinern gefördert
und sie hat vor allem
Stiftungsprofessuren finanziert eine
davon die wahrscheinlich wichtigste hat
Harald Matthes er ist nicht nur Leiter
des gemeinschaftskrankenhauses Havelhöhe
sondern er ist vor allem dank der
Software die Stiftung Professor der
Charité in Berlin
ein genialer Schachzug Professor der
Charité mehr Renommee mehr Augenhöhe
geht nicht
Peter schnell selbst ein überzeugter
Anthroposoph ist einer der wichtigsten
Förderer der anthroposophischen Medizin
seine Stiftung wollte ich mir mal
anschauen
Milliarden schwer und kaum bekannt sie
liegt ziemlich versteckt auf einem Hügel
nahe Darmstadt
unsichtbares Geld quasi
ich hatte versucht ein Interview mit
Peter schnell zu bekommen es wurde per
Mail sehr schnell abgelehnt also
probiere ich es persönlich
ich bin kaum aus dem Auto ausgestiegen
da kommt ein Vorstandsmitglied auf mich
zu
er sagt dass Peter schnell sehr
zurückgezogen lebt keine Interviews gibt
auch sonst will sich aus der Stiftung
niemand öffentlich äußern
die anthroposophische Medizin ist auch
dank des von der Software AG Stiftung
finanzierten Masterplans inzwischen ein
fester Bestandteil unseres
Gesundheitssystems
in Jena bin ich mit Jutta Hübner
verabredet sie ist Professorin und
Expertin für komplementäre Heilverfahren
[Musik]
was halten sie von anthroposophischer
Medizin
blitzgefährlich und mit das
gefährlichste was wir derzeit haben eine
Medizin die nicht ehrlich sagt was
Fakten und was Wissenschaft ist die
Patienten Gefühle von Schuld gibt wo es
keine Schuld gibt die die Ressourcen von
unseren Patienten und aus der Medizin
raus saugt ist wahnsinnig gefährlich für
das System gibt es einen belastbaren
Nachweis dass anthroposophische Medizin
anthroposophische Heilmittel wirksam
sind ich kenne keinen einzigen
keinen einzigen Nachweis ich kenne
keinen einzigen Nachweis wenn es keinen
belastbaren Nachweis gibt warum ist die
anthroposophische Medizin dann für so
viele Menschen attraktiv viele
Anthroposophen nehmen sich einfach mehr
Zeit für die Patienten auch die
Therapeuten die Musik oder Tanz oder
andere Therapie machen haben Zeit für
den Patienten aber diese Zuwendung ist
doch was Gutes oder nicht ja das
Entscheidende ist nur dass die
Anthroposophen den Menschen
vermitteln wollen dass nicht die
Zuwendung das eigentliche ist sondern
die Mittel und auch die Art genau der
Zuwendung und die sehen wir eben sehr
kritisch wenn ich dabei Mittel gebe die
nicht wirksam sind dann vermittle ich
den Menschen ja einen Glauben an etwas
unwirksames und das kann im Falle
ernsthafte Erkrankungen zu falschen
Entscheidungen führen okay also sie
sagen die Zuwendung die hilft den
Menschen aber es sind nicht die
Medikamente genau
[Musik]
das Problem ist nur
anthroposophische Präparate wie etwa das
Meteoreisen werden in Deutschland als
Arzneimittel anerkannt ohne dafür einen
wissenschaftlichen Nachweis ihrer
Wirksamkeit erbringen zu müssen sowie
herkömmlicher Arzneimittel
das gleiche gilt übrigens für die
Homöopathie
noch dazu übernehmen Krankenkassen
häufig die Kosten für anthroposophische
oder eben auch homöopathische
Heilmethoden und Heilmittel genau das
stellt Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach gerade in Frage zumindest für
die Homöopathie
[Musik]
das ist ja einer der Gründe warum die
Patienten immer wieder glauben dass das
wirksam ist was dort gemacht wird weil
sie haben ja eher die Haltung die
Krankenkasse zahlt ja ganz wenig also
wenn sie es bezahlt muss es ja wirken
sonst würde sie es ja nicht bezahlen
also weil es von den Krankenkassen
übernommen wird glauben viele Menschen
das muss ja was helfen eindeutig also
wenn ich sowas in Patienten Vorträgen
bespreche dann ist das eines der
häufigsten Argumente wenn ich kritisch
komme dass jemand sagt aber die
Krankenkasse bezahlt es doch Karl
Lauterbach hat zusammentritt gesagt die
Gesundheitspolitik kann aus meiner Sicht
nur erfolgreich sein wenn sie sich an
der evidenzbasierten Medizin orientiert
was wäre ihre Erwartung an ihn was
würden Sie sich wünschen ich würde mir
das sehr wünschen weil ich glaube dass
wir dann dahin kommen was in anderen
Ländern völlig normal und üblich ist
nämlich durch solche Sachen zumindest
nicht über Solidarsystem finanziert
werden wir wollen es ja nicht komplett
abschaffen wenn ein Patient das möchte
soll er das tun aber er soll eben
erkennen können okay das ist eine andere
Form der Wirksamkeit ist nicht
nachgewiesen wenn ich persönlich meine
Zeit da rein investieren will meine
Gesundheit da rein investieren will mein
Geld investieren will ist es okay und
das wäre glaube ich die Präzision und
Transparenz die wir brauchen
[Musik]
Transparenz das ist ein gutes und
wichtiges Stichwort weil nicht alles was
die Anthroposophie angestoßen hat ist
schlecht im Gegenteil sie hat die
Landwirtschaft ökologischer gemacht sie
hat in der Medizin den Menschen in den
Mittelpunkt gestellt da war sie oft
Vorreiter nur das ist eben nicht alles
Anthroposophie ist eben auch Karma
kosmische Kräfte und immer wieder die
Überzeugung das Wissenschaft nicht alles
ist das Wissenschaft begrenzt ist und
genau das ist gefährlich in der Pandemie
haben wir gemerkt was es bedeutet wenn
das Vertrauen in die Wissenschaft fehlt
die anthroposophische denke die Esoterik
ist tief in unsere Gesellschaft
eingesickert viel stärker als uns das
bewusst ist über Homöopathie wird viel
diskutiert gerade im Augenblick über
Anthroposophie noch zu wenig
[Musik]